welcome to the 50 50 challenge
with my mom hi mom hi so we went through
just because my mom was curious of what
it was we've already done
one of these things and it was between a
foot binding and an aussie puppy and you
what did you see
i saw cutie's puppy cutest puppy that's
what this game is all about you just see
cute stuff
and you pick which one you want makes
sense yes okay
so it's either dog vomiting or dog's
hilarious face after eating a bee of
course i'm going to the second one
you want to choose the second one yeah
okay all right
for you let's go cute dogs on an
escalator
or weird person with hammerhead shark
face all right so you want the first one
of course
dog dog isn't my favorite
what if i told you there's a subreddit
for people that hate dogs
so you want the cute dogs on an
escalator of course of course of course
[Laughter]
oh my god all right so i may have misled
you
this game's not so much about picking
what you want
it's about you'll randomly get one or
the other
on a 50 50 chance right that's
weird that's real yeah that's real that
guy that's wrong yeah he pulled his eyes
right out of his sockets
a compilation of cute kittens or the
station nightclub fire
oh of course number one you want number
one of course
okay all right oh it's the it's the [ __ ]
why are you putting
fire i chose the other one you didn't
you don't get to choose them
do you know what a 50 50 chance is which
one is more
no i don't understand i chose the other
one and you don't get to choose
you don't choose oh i don't choose it
okay where's the audio oh don't tell me
the audio is not working
ah god bless
it's a living hell yeah so it's not good
oh it's terrible
yeah so this game isn't fun it's not fun
i rather see it cute and fun that's
that's the risk
that's the risk all right man falls off
motorcycle
or man does cool vape bubble trick you
can also say pass
b okay b you want b yeah all right let's
hope for b yeah yeah
i think i've seen this before you seen
this i think i've done this one before
wow wow pretty cool right
let's do this one police dog give cpr or
women angry over lack of cheese
of course number one yeah what about the
angry women
i don't care some people get angry for a
little thing like that it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous cheese cheese
you save about 100 calories going to
your fat cell
that's true you should say thank you for
saving my diet today and say
thank you for saving 100 calorie from
going into fat
cell yes so i can eat cheesecake you get
all the cheesecake
get cheesecake after say thank you for
saving a hundred calories but eat
cheesecake
negotiate problem not get angry
let's see the functions it's not loading
here i know what this video is i
i know it's already going to give you
police dog so like doing cpr so i'm just
going to show you the video to make you
happy
oh
[Laughter]
absolutely adorable oh my goodness
mom i have something to tell you well
i've been
protecting you because i have not been
introducing and not safe for work
in results but you're not playing the
true game
unless you have a risk of being scarred
for life
what does that mean
don't i have a hard life yet
i thought i had through ups and down
oh come on what else can i have to go
experience
come on you're right you're right mom
you're right
you're right when you're right you're
right okay but you gotta play the true
honest
the true honest um backs of life yeah
you gotta
oof oh no
why why why why i'm just reading oh no
what what are you doing i'm trying to
protect you
why is this so terrible yeah
do you not know how this works so the
most
most of the reddit 5050s they are
usually
something nice or cute or maybe like
some naked girl or something and then
it's versus
horrible death mame murders
very bad life scarring things
you know what i have lived my life
i'm ready to see some ugly stuff
let me figure out some good stuff for
you
oh no come on okay all right
all right okay let's do tryptophobia
or adorable bird shakes hand oh of
course
number b number b
and of course number b bell settle down
settle down you're gonna have to see
these things too okay
well let's watch all right oh my god
what is that oh what is that what is
that what is that what is that
it's a monkey with the horrible oh it's
got bot flies
so bot flies they're these horrible
things
they egg they plant eggs in your skin
and then the larva grows in your body
yeah no good
yeah you ready all right
thank you she's giving me a cpr
[Laughter]
mouse finds new friend or mouse eaten
alive
number one please i'm gonna just open
one eye
[Laughter]
oh no
i'm sorry i need to wash my
eyes
okay you we can stop at any time no no
i'm okay you're tough you're tough
one we'll get a good one soon right
we'll get a good one later
bunny eating raspberries here
she's fine she's fine she landed
she landed with my scratch on my face
are you okay
no not yet oh it's going to be wrapped
it's going to be red
this video has come to you this is the
trouble that my own mother is going
through for your entertainment
smash that like button because of what
my mom is going
i'm doing this terrible oh horrible
experience you better smash that like
button
all right bunny eating raspberry or
parasites bursting out of a praying
mantis
all right oh it's we've gotten three bad
ones in a row
apparently it's uh the praying mantis
bursting
thing what is that oh
he's dying he's sorry he wants to get
out of the hill
what is that
[Music]
it's like a worm
how'd that thing fit in that prank
mantis
all right let's move on shall we woman
experiencing horror vr
grabs wrong end of dog for solace or
dead animal getting violently
torn to shreds by piranhas leaving only
the bones
oh what's that
oh it's piranhas they're munching like
an on an old skull
that's a fish yeah have you seen perum
okay that's actually fascinating it's
morbid but that's just nature
that's nature nature does that piranhas
are
vicious you've gotten a disproportionate
amount of bad ones i'm actually
surprised okay
aftermath of man mauled by bear or my
cat in a blanket
be
nice right that's nice this game fun
game fun oh no you got a little scratch
now it's going red right yes just a
little bump like it's okay you're gonna
have a vicious like villain scar but
that was pretty cool right that's
totally worth
almost seeing all the horrible things
right a brazen
alien or a bird narrowly escapes
death a brazilian alien i don't know
what b
i don't know what those mean
[Music]
what is that oh
it's not alien it's just disabled dog
comforts baby
or person cuts open their own arm of
course a
i rather see i think we all know what
we'd rather see
man cutting his arm open oh
that looks like a lucy oh that's my lucy
totally worth it right totally make my
home
warm that's cute that's cute and the
other ones make your
heart sad and broken
you want that oh no no no you want that
one chinchilla eating a dorito or man
injects poop into his penis hole
oh no why
he's gonna get some serious std
yeah that's the std that's the worst of
his concerns
do you wanna try that one no no no we're
gonna try that one no
chinchilla
[Laughter]
see that's the game you can't you can't
say no to everything
okay let's just do let's do three more
okay that's it and
we're done okay cute puppy versus not so
cute ankle
broke it remember one time you broke
yeah my arm was in mind of you
my arm was very much like that foot
except you know when he was about nine
or ten you know he was playing in the
playground he fell
to the ground and he said he the arm was
broken
completely right yeah i said it i said
and then he said it
i said it myself myself and i went
when i came to you know pick you up pick
you guys up from playground you said mom
i fell off the monkey bar and i broke my
arm but i said it hey
[Laughter]
i said what in the world you did well i
didn't want to
hurt my face so i just decided to put my
hand down to protect my face you say
that
my beautiful face anyway let's click
away from this angle that's nice
that's nice a cute baby laughing
hysterically
or a dead baby preserved in jar by
mother
oh my gosh
i don't know about that there's a
warning there's a warning
oh no oh no oh no oh
oh no that's too much that's so sad
i know but why i don't know why
what's wrong with her i don't know
why in the world she traumatized every
single day of her life
by looking at like that that looks so
sad to the point she have to moan every
single
of their life you know life happens okay
that's it's part of life you have to let
it go
you have to let it go okay and live for
the best
you know what i mean we have to let it
go it makes sense
yeah that's mommy pliers advice for
today okay
spider cat which i imagine is a cat in
like a costume and it's real cute
or a fish hook in the eye oh my gosh
this will be the last one if it ends on
a good note
we'll end it and it'll be great spider
cat
yeah yeah yeah
i'm sorry
maybe maybe we could end it on because
if we pick this one again you remember
the cute dogs on escalator weird person
with hammerhead
if we pick it again we might get the
cute dogs okay we'll just try it again
and
and and um yeah yeah
all right okay we'll end it there
because that's cute that's better
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you mom for going through
this
i'm sorry i have to subject you to that
but gosh darn it think of the views
anyway thank you everybody so much you
can
check out my mom's youtube channel in
the description below
i don't have no youtube channel it'll
either be it'll either be
my mom's youtube channel or a video of a
cow being eaten by piranhas
50 50 shots okay you can either hit the
like button or ring the bell
50 50 shot if you hit the like button
i'm gonna show you how to make a korean
dish
which is um next time
we're probably gonna do it anyway but
smash that like button
you know how it is oh make it very
simple and healthy okay yeah it won't
take no more than maybe your time of 10
minutes five minutes to make it just 10
minutes that's it
so watch out for that let's make some
bulgogi
all right thank you everybody so much
for watching uh check out the
description for more videos that i've
done with my mom
and as always we'll see you in the next
video and merry christmas
merry christmas bye-bye
[Music]
you